I'M DRUNK.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S GETTING HIS ASS
KICKED BY A GHOST.
WHEN YOU'RE THIS DRUNK,
LIFE IS A FIELD SOBRIETY TEST.
WILLIAM H MACY'S IN THE YARD
AGAIN.
TURN AROUND, GO HOME.
GO HOME, YOU'RE DRUNK.
>> POINT-COUNTERPOINT.
THIS IS AT THE PREAKNESS STAKES,
WHICH IS THE KENTUCKY DERBY'S
INBRED COUSIN.
[LAUGHTER]
GETTING PELTED WITH BEER CANS ON
TOP OF A PORTA-POTTY IS STILL
BETTER THAN SETTING FOOT INSIDE
OF ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
SO CLOSE!
WE'RE NOT BLURRING ANYTHING.
THAT'S HOW SMALL
HIS WHISKEY DICK IS.
HARD TO SAY WHO SHOULD BE MORE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES.
IF YOU'RE SECRETLY FILMING
STRANGERS FROM YOUR STALL,
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO DO
A LITTLE SOUL SEARCHING.
NOTICE, IT STARTS OUT
LIKE EVERY OTHER VIDEO
WE GET FROM ENGLAND--
WITH A DRUNK IN A PUB.
EITHER HE LOST A BET
OR THE ENGLISH VERSION
OF THE BIGGEST LOSER
IS WAY MORE INTENSE
THAN OURS.
[audience laughter]
OH, WHAT A SHOT.
CAN A DART TO THE SPINE
DO DAMAGE?
APPARENTLY NOT WHEN YOUR
MUFFIN TOP IS MADE OF KEVLAR.
- YOU'RE WAY TOO DRUNK
TO USE A SHOTGUN.
THANKS MOM.
PUT IT DOWN ON THE GROUND
RIGHT THERE IN THE FRONT.
[bleep] YOU.